welcome to PFT Ooty on Yahoo Sports he's
Peter King I'm Mike Florio and some of
the big issues around the National
Football League the Dallas Cowboys had
five and three coming out of their bye
week they have a big Sunday night game
on NBC against the Minnesota Vikings
Peter what is keeping the Cowboys from
joining the NFL's an elite teams or are
they already there and their record just
doesn't simply reflect it you know Mike
I think consistency of play I think
that's the biggest thing they've been
sort of you know playing in and out
football and I think Monday night
against the Giants one of the things
that you saw is they really move the
ball very very well up and down the
field but there are these patches of
inconsistency and these turnovers you
know dak Prescott first series of the
game throwing the interception Antoine
Bethea you know losing the fumble later
on I think this is just this a team that
I think all of us think has got a chance
to play deep into January but they just
haven't been consistent enough
especially behind an in and out
offensive line you know what our earlier
on Tuesday on the PFT live show and
NBCSN you referred to the sloppiness of
the Cowboys and at some point you got to
ask is the sloppiness a reflection of
the coaching and the question still
hover around Jason Garrett no contract
beyond this season and I really do feel
like his future hinges on not just
getting the team at the playoffs but
being competitive when they get that hem
into the NFC Championship since 1995 do
you really think when we look at this
crowd at NFC field does this strike you
as a team that can navigate presumably
having to win at least one on the road
in the divisional round to get to the
NFC Championship game Mike I think it's
going to be really hard for them in this
conference this year you know they're
not better than San Francisco I don't
think they're better than Seattle but
they're close they're there in the
league they're in a league with Seattle
and the Rams and Minnesota
and probably Green Bay even though Green
Bay beat them at home you know and and
again you know you look at New Orleans
and that is that's a really tough
matchup for them too so winning any of
those games on the road against any of
those teams it's not impossible but I
just call it unlikely yeah and I'll tell
you what they're gonna have their hands
full in that division with the
Philadelphia Eagles if they come on down
the stretch they have to play the Eagles
again in Philadelphia later this year
you mentioned the Rams and the Vikings
two of the games the Cowboys will be
playing over the balance of the regular
season we're learning a lot about the
Cowboys in the next several weeks they
have a tough game at New England if they
can go there and beat the Patriots I
think we view them differently down the
stretch run but it all comes down to
January and I think with each passing
year when they do get to the playoffs
the fact that it's been so long since
they've been to the NFC Championship
that puts so much pressure on them in
that divisional round Peter it's almost
like the Bengals every year they got to
the playoffs because it's been so long
since they want a playoff game it puts
more pressure on them it's a talking
point it's a focus of attention and it's
hard to get the players not to be
distracted by it and I think that'll be
a challenge if they do get to the
divisional round forgetting that it has
been 24 years since they've punched
through and just focusing on that game
Mike I think there's one other thing to
remember as you look at down the road
for the Dallas Cowboys number one I've
always thought nobody's ever told me
this but this is just my opinion from
being around the team I've always
thought that one day Jerry Jones would
have loved to hire Sean Payton as his
head coach
now that the the Saints have reopened
that almost certainly is not going to be
a possibility then who's the next guy in
line maybe Lincoln Riley I'm told that
Lincoln Riley at least for now does not
want to make that jump to the NFL who
knows maybe Jones could be very
persuasive
if the Cowboys crash and burn this year
but it's only because I'm saying that
everybody says get rid of Jason Garrett
well who is next and my feeling is that
two of the biggest candidates are
probably not going to be on the
margit for Jerry Jones to go shopping
with some would say keep an eye on the
local XFL coach Bob Stoops of the Dallas
renegades that he could parlay his short
season oh he may not even who knows he
may not even be there by the time the
XFL starts in February because if Jerry
Jones comes calling he's gonna say see
you later xfo will say see you later for
now check out more PFT ot of videos on
Yahoo Sports
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports